well we're somewhere I have no idea
where we are really we're somewhere on
the Swiss French Broad I don't even know
if we're in France or Switzerland what I
do know is is that all around us is the
Large Hadron Collider so we're bang in
the middle of the Ring so we've got
Atlas about which is one of the big
detectives about four and a half
kilometers that way and we've got CMS
which is the other big detector about
four and a half kilometers that way so
we're right in the middle of the of the
ring it's just so it's below our feet
all around us okay so the big story is
that it was going to create a black hole
in the collision you know okay that
hasn't happened now that there is a
possibility that it will create a black
hole in the collision this this idea
stems from models with actual dimensions
that have come out of string theory
basically what happens in those model is
is that is that the the strength of
gravity gravity is actually a much
stronger force than we previously
thought
it just looks weak to us who is a sort
of if you like a lower dimensional
observer so the picture is that you have
this we live on this island this island
universe which is four dimensional and
it's within this sea of extra dimensions
and basically those Islanders have this
perception of gravity which is different
to reality and realities gravity and
what gravity is a much stronger force
than weak than we thought that makes it
easier to produce black holes in
collisions why well because what you're
doing it think about what you're doing
in a collision you're you're basically
smacking through two things together
they've both got a lot of energy and
you're cramming a lot of energy into a
very very small volume okay and and you
know there's bounds on how much energy
you can you can collapse into a small
volume because energy and matter
equivalence that is bound on how much
mass you can collapse into a small
volume before you create a black hole
and of course if that black gravity is
stronger then that process becomes
easier and more likely to happen so you
could create a black hole I completely
understand what your explanation about
creating a black hole because we're
cramming so much into such small space
we already get black holes in our
universe they can be created in our
island universe and that didn't require
extra dimensions and things like that I
can see how this danger now but I can't
see what the extra dimensions angle okay
so the diff
between those sorts of black holes the
astrophysical black holes in the kind
you might produce the LHC are that those
are those are very large they're very
large black holes okay they've been
formed from stellar collapse you know
death of a star collapses and forms of
black holes of a star of a certain size
at least the difference between those
and the ones at the LHC the other see
ones are very much smaller but the fact
that they're smaller is what actually
makes them safe okay well we don't need
to worry about them
it's as if they exist of course and
because basically the smaller a black
hole is the hotter it is so we normally
talk about when we talk about black
holes we say that black because nothing
can escape from them not even light but
actually that's not actually true
something can escape from a black hole
and it's something called Hawking
radiation which was named after Stephen
Hawking it's basically what you get when
you apply quantum mechanics to the event
horizon of a black hole you realize that
they're not as black as they seem and
they can give off this this type of
radiation the smaller a black hole the
hotter it is the more of this the more
easily it gives off this radiation and
the LHC black holes will will will be
very very small therefore very very hot
and so they'll evaporate through Hawking
radiation very quickly you know almost
instantaneously but of course we've
never actually observed Hawking
radiation it's just a theory it's not
something that's been experimentally
proven yet although we do believe it's
true but actually so that might not be a
good reason to sort of a lay people's
fears but what we do know is that is
that nature performs LHC like
experiments all the time okay so the
earth is being bombarded by cosmic rays
and in the lifetime of the earth we've
had about a million LHC like experiments
sort of created essentially as these
cosmic rays at very high energies
bombard the earth and collide with the
particles in the earth in the earth
essentially nothing weird has happened
okay we've had no create craziness we
hope the earth has not disappeared into
a black hole now what you could say is
okay well the difference between the
kind of black hole that might get
created in one lose one of those cosmic
ray collisions compared to the ones that
the LHC is that the LHC ones will be
very slow moving and so they hang around
whereas the maybe the cosmic ray ones
would just get created but get shot out
of the earth almost immediately and
because of that you know you might say
well okay so that's not a good
to allay your fears but then we look at
neutron stars neutron stars are very
very dense those are getting bombarded
by the cosmic rays as well and they're
so dense that any black hole of that
would be created wouldn't be able to
just get away okay it would stay there
and those haven't been swallowed off in
the same way so you know because you've
got neutron stars because we're still
here you know we've got good reason to
believe that the LHC is not very good
reason to believe that the LHC is not
going to swallow up the earth what would
it look like if this area got swallowed
up by a black hole okay so so it's this
it this is it would take a long flight
this is one the other MIT people sort of
often believe that it's going to swallow
up the earth in nanoseconds let's say
hypothetically that you know all these
effects don't play and that actually it
will swallow up good fuel sale happen in
nanoseconds but that's not true it would
take ten thousand to a hundred thousand
years to actually accrete the whole of
the earth and the reason is basically
because it starts out so small it starts
out so small and you know it takes a
long time to get to a macroscopic size
where it can actually really start to
pull things in so what would we see well
basically things would start to get
flatter so not much would happen for as
I said for about ten thousand years
things that start to get flattered all
those mountains out there they'd be they
just slowly start to come down come down
come down and then eventually you know
everything had just slowly slowly slowly
slowly slowly go down until you had sort
of this sphere forming around the black
hole and then eventually I think just
collapses into it because I sort of call
YouTube video and it was like it was
like everything was falling down like
Niagara Falls it was now I wouldn't be
like that it would be more a case of
literally the edge smoothing out around
it and any structure sort of
disappearing because one of the key
features of a book that we know about
black holes is is that they have what we
say no hair
they have no hair they have no features
okay they're perfectly smooth objects
perfectly round
so the black holes and the sort of the
most famous crazy thing that could
happen at the that people have talked
about that could happen at the LHC but
that won't happen and another one is is
the idea of strangelets which is
slightly less famous but also another
possible concern that people have talked
about so a strangelet is is a is a bound
state of quarks so these are silver
Tomic particles so we talk about protons
and neutrons they're made up of quarks
in particular they made up of up and
down quarks what a strangelet is it's a
combination of three quarks up down and
the strange quark but it's a lot of them
sort of put together to form one sort of
large object if you like so potentially
you're bigger than the proton like a big
quark soup if you like yeah yeah yeah a
big blob of quarks right yeah exactly
it's exactly what it's like you know you
might think oh this is going to be very
unstable in particular the strange quark
wants to decay into the office down
quark so it's you think this is a very
unstable object but there's something
called a poly exclusion principle which
says that a fermion and all these quarks
are fermions can't exist in the same
state as an identical fermium and so
having more of these fermions that are
different so up down and strange means
that you all these failures can lie lie
in there in a lower energy state sort of
it's simultaneously okay so it can
actually be more stable even than a
nucleus of conventional nucleus so all
that means is is that you have this
object a stranger which is potentially
more stable than a nucleus nucleus of
made of protons and neutrons which
within them have got these quarks and
the other really strange thing about
strangelets is that in some cases if
they're if they're surface tension
exceeds a critical value they actually
become more stable the bigger they get
so you think of putting more quarks onto
them they actually get more stable okay
so this is quite worrying because what
would happen then is if you get this
strange let created at the LHC just a
little one but it sees an EM it sees you
know a normal nucleus and then it's
advantageous
it's energetically favorable for that
nucleus to be turned into more of a
strange it suits for it to combine with
that nucleus and create a bigger
strangelet and so on and so on and so
and create an ever more strangelets
until eventually the whole world has
turned into a strangelet now dude so
there's actually there's actually this
is a theory this actually this process
can turn neutron stars into what's
called quark stars and but it's
completely hypothetical it's based on a
you know a reasonably exotic theory but
again we don't think this is going to
happen at the LHC and there's a good
reason to believe this there's another
Collider in New York called Rick which
is doing similar things to the LHC it's
smashing you know one of the things that
LHC will do is smash a heavy lead ions
together Rick is doing the same thing
with gold and there was the same worries
about Rick that that would produce these
these strangelets
and it hasn't and actually one of the
things about the LHC is that it's
actually doing these things at higher
energies and the thing about quarks is
is that they don't like to hang around
with all the quarks as much at higher
energies I'm not a scare monger might
and I love the LHC but your sort of
defense usually seems to be it hasn't
happened before is that good enough well
if we know of events that litter you
know basically that in nature like I say
these cosmic rays these cosmic ray
events you know nature's doing and we
can't control them nature's making them
happen and was like well nature's due
and it hasn't caused anything weird
happens so why does why'd you expect it
to happen for us it's you know it's it's
a reasonable reason that look that guy
over there is doing it nothing weird
happened so I'm good Africa it could do
vacuum decay as well if you want vote
for was this another day yeah yeah so so
there's another possibility is that
people have talked about is this idea of
vacuum decay which is so the universe
sort of exists in as an excitation about
a particular vacuum state so it's
excited clearly we've got planets we've
got all this structure around right but
it's an excitation about a particular
vacuum state there could be other vacuum
states and one of the and one of the
concerns
people have said is that we could be
causing such a large perturbation a
large wiggle in what's going on in this
vacuum state that actually we tumble out
of the vacuum state and that would
literally you know that would create a
bubble of new of a new universe sort of
where the LHC is again there's these
sorts of events going on all over the
universe and you're not seeing these
bubbles get created you know I said this
about LHC events have occurred about a
million times with cosmic rays hitting
the earth there's you know billions of
LHC events going on every second with
cosmic rays across the across the
universe so you know we really don't
have anything to worry about
it's noisy it's it's light if you've
been on a ship on them you know across
across the English Channel or something
and you're on you're on the the home of
the engines constantly the hard on color
limiter and within that you've got the
the inner detector and the pipe itself
so literally it is deep within that is
where all where it's all going on where
it's all kicking off